I don't think it is effective you see in
order to support other people first of
all you really have to believe that
those we cannot use political ploys when
when we don't like Iran we want to
support the I remember about Afghanistan
when I came to us in 97 I was so mad
that nobody was talking about what women
were apart from a small group of women
here give them credit the feminist
majority especially we're talking about
Taliban and but the majority of society
was silenced the administration's
different administrations were mainly
silent ok so now Taliban is I is is bad
but let we let them be four timing then
911 happens and all of a sudden when we
are invading Afghanistan we remember
Afghani women that they have been
suffering and their Taliban then we drop
them are you hearing the administration
talking about a funny women anymore
they're suffering I can tell you that
they are being killed and also said so
you admit middle US foreign policy
circles should learn that these are not
things you play with if you think about
Iranian people's right to democracy you
can't constantly vacillate well if you
like the regime you shut up about it if
you don't like it you'll offer cures for
it so that is the first thing the second
thing is that what we need is not money
you want to put money into promoting
democracy in Iran put money into
education of democracy via internet wire
Radio Free Iran Radio Farda or VOA it is
a cultural entity the most hopeful thing
about Iran and and this work might be
dashed I'm not saying I'm not optimistic
and hopeful the most helpful thing about
Iran it has it has a vibrant civil
society it has people who
have wood their flesh and blood
understood what individual rights means
and they want change let us help them
change from within through bringing
education of democracy through bringing
their voices back through talking about
what Iranian workers struggles right now
Iranian women struggles money to
individuals money like weapons doesn't
solve the problem culture does you know
so that is my critique of that I'm not
saying whether mrs. rice was
well-intentioned or not but intentions
don't come into this you know depth does
I don't think there's any depth to these
programs
you